there are basic canons of ethics I  haven't looked at them lately but  presumably approving our giving opinions  on transactions which you're aware to be  nothing more than fraud is not part of  the canons of ethics presumably looking  at a registration statement at helping  the registrar figure out how to lie so  as to make huge amounts of money for the  insiders as people lose their life  savings  cannot I just don't believe that's part  of the Canon of ethics there has to be  some restraints and I'm sure there are  just they've been ignored now there's a  difference you want to have a zealous  lawyer zealous representation but I  cannot believe that the Canon of ethics  allow lawyers to lie and cheat and steal